chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year
for the first time since 2020 the Cairns
cup is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd see
seasonal Classic Events are back the
summer chess classic August 2nd followed
up with the St Louis Norm Invitational
and the winter chess classic wraps up
the year in December September brings
back everyone's favorite chess night
Alex where some of the world's best
don't even know what's coming and
compete for a 150 000 prize fund 30
players across three Fields come
together in St Louis for the U.S juniors
girls and Senior championships starting
July 15th in partnership with U.S chess
the best in the U.S fight to be the
nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels